making Aviation green is a huge
challenge flying is such a big part of
our lives and we have to balance that
with the fact that it contributes hugely
to global warming we've left it a long
time we've now got a very short window
within which we need to get emissions
from this sector down to nearly zero we
need to be throwing everything at this
problem that we can think of
there are two big reasons why Aviation
presents a unique challenge in terms of
climate change the first is that more
and more people are flying and the
second is that flying remains almost
totally dependent on fossil fuels we
haven't got green technologies available
yet for the aviation sector
and that's roughly equivalent to the
total emissions from the UK and Germany
combined
in 2019 Airlines carried around 4.5
billion passengers on flight and we're
really expecting that to grow
[Music]
globally just one percent of the
population many of whom are frequent
flyers generate half of all emissions
from the aviation sector
foreign there is no Silver Bullet to get
Aviation to become green but rather a
whole set of different options each with
pros and cons
are vertical looking extensions that
we've added at the end of the Wings and
what they do is to increase the
efficiency of the Wings these winglets
were inspired by birds and we are
currently looking at much more features
from birth wings and bird flight and
incorporating them into our aircraft the
aviation industry is really good at
making itself more efficient through a
mixture of improving technology and
learning to fly the aircraft more
efficiently if you look at history we
are improving the efficiency of our
aircraft at about two percent per year
that is definitely very little and it
cannot continue forever so we definitely
need to change our aircraft fuels
jet engines at the moment run on fuel
made from fossil fuels so it's really
important that we find ways to replace
that in aircraft biofuels are a form of
fuel which is made from plant-based
materials the one possible example is
vegetable oil which exists in very large
quantities and can be transformed into a
biofuel
foreign
for instance if we were to replace the
entire jet fuel used in the UK with
biofuels we will be using about 68 of
the land that we currently use to grow
our food another possibility is what we
call E fuels which is scrubbing the
carbon dioxide from the air and putting
it through chemical processes that turn
it back into jet fuel again so it turns
into a circular process where it's all
going into the atmosphere and then
coming back out again one big
disadvantage of e-fuels is that they are
very expensive not only in terms of
their cost but also in terms of the
energy that they use
hydrogen is a gas that if you react it
with the oxygen in the air can release a
lot of energy that makes it potentially
a really good aviation fuel but it's not
without its problems for a start we
can't store it in the current designs of
airplanes secondly at the moment about
95 percent of our hydrogen comes from
fossil fuels hydrogen is very explosive
which causes a serious safety
considerations designing manufacturing
and Licensing hydrogen power aircraft is
something that is bound to take decades
and cost in the regions of tens of
billions of pounds
electric airplanes are still incredibly
rare so I'm one of the very few people
in the world who's had a chance to Pilot
an electric airplane
whilst it's possible to make an electric
car that works well if you put those
same batteries into an airplane it's
simply too heavy to fly
there's no doubt that it's going to take
a lot of resources particularly energy
that's going to cost a lot and it's
going to require a huge amount of effort
from business and from government
working together with the cooperation
and support of the public it will be
great if there was one kind of fix it
all solution that we could put in place
for this sector
unfortunately
we're going to have to do everything we
can think of and it's all probably going
to be quite challenging a lot of the
technologies that we need for Greening
Aviation are still some decades apart
they are very expensive and the electric
energy that would be required from a
renewable source will also be a very
expensive and time consuming to set in
place alongside that just as importantly
we're probably going to have to fly less
because we've left it so long that just
isn't time left the aircraft coming off
the production line today will probably
still be flying in 2050 which is the
date by which we have to be at net zero
emissions we need to be building the
kind of society in which there are good
alternatives to Flying so if you choose
to take holiday domestically in your own
country that will start to create that
kind of demand that will help make a
more sustainable future
I love stick flight before my daughter
was born and she's going to be a
teenager this summer
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video